la pluie n'arrête pas le pic noir
quelques dizaines d'adhérents à
l'association qui lutte contre
l'implantation d'un center parks à
poligny ont fait la route depuis le jura
le tribunal administratif examine ce
jour leur recours contre le projet local
d'urbanisme paix est lui qui permet
l'implantation de quatre son cottage par
le groupe pierre et vacances en forêt de
tartare au et pour leur premier
contentieux en l'espace de cinq ans les
opposants sont plutôt optimistes
nous avons un bon retour du rapporteur
public qui est
qui préconise quand même carrément
l'annulation totale ou partielle du pmu
ça c'est plutôt bien pour nous les
défenseurs de l'environnement
s'inquiètent de la bétonisation de la
forêt de l'exploitation de la ressource
en eau à ces craintes le maire de
poligny répond invariablement emploi et
développement
l'activité n'est pas abondante dans le
jura à 270 habitants quand on amène 300
emplois et dont 500 durant la phase de
construction plus les emplois indirects
je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire la fine
bouche une activité économique
importante
quelle que soit la décision du tribunal
rendue dans trois semaines il est
probable que le perdant face appel
mettant à nouveau le projet de center
parcs ce jurassien en stand by pour
quelques années